this past sunday rainbow six siege's
sixth sixth invitational came to a close
and for the most part it was riveting
refreshing and all around a resounding
success
again for the most part the competition
was stiffer than ever before the year 7
roadmap lived up to its promise to usher
in the so-called year of siege and we
all got to watch as north america's lean
spamming chosen one hoisted the hammer
in spectacular fashion
so why is it that ubisoft decided to
sour all of that with one terribly timed
blog post why did it send the community
into an uproar
and more importantly how did that uproar
inspire ubisoft to backtrack on it
okay so it feels kind of weird to do a
sub throw in a video like this so i
won't what i will do is say that it has
been a long ass time since i have had a
good reason to do a siege don't at me
and hot damn am i glad to be back this
is gonna be a big year for rainbow six
and i hope that you're as psyched as i
am to watch it unfold all right let's
get into it for starters the esports
stuff since
despite what you might glean from the
comment section of this show
that is actually what we talk about
after two awesome grueling weeks of play
the 2022 6 invitational ended with north
america's resident bridesmaids team bolo
mid
taking the cake having made it to si
through the open qualifier no step of
tsm's journey was certain especially
considering they'd secured back to back
third and fourth place finishes at si
2020 and si 2021 and yet after losing to
empire in the upper bracket final
tsm showed up to play on sunday
executing a juicy yet unexpected double
whammy dumpstering faze before running
it back against the russians in the
grand final empire have come so close
before but they've fallen short and
they'll do so again tsm said trust the
process the process just won you
a world championship
tsm are your six invitational 2022
world champs
they come through the open qualifier
they had no chance at making here
besides that last option and against all
odds as one of the lowest seeds at this
entire event
they've done it north america on top
i won't get into the nitty-gritty of
their fairy tale storyline since
well
that'll be for a later video what i will
say is that if you've been following
this roster since the very beginning
like we're talking achieved two-year
challenger lee grind almost getting
relegated once he got to pro league
taking a chance on merc the bolo
acquisition
you love to see these boys in particular
hoisting the hammer i will also say that
cheeky monikers aside there was nothing
individualistic about team solomids
performance
did bolo do disgusting unthinkable
things to people's faces
yes obviously he's bolo that's what he
does and for those of us who've been
beau leavers since the ranked demon days
it was genuinely awe-inspiring to watch
this sweet humble as hell youtuber
fulfill his dreams
this ladies and gentlemen is what
esports is all about
congratulations to tsm
they are your six invitational
2022
champions and a lifts its third hammer
but from a performance standpoint it was
undoubtedly my boy achieved and entry
god slash in-game leader merck who put
up the biggest stats and ended up
getting the mvp nods
and rightfully so those dudes were
insanely impactful across the board
there were other equally awesome story
lines as well of course
damon onigiri going big sonics
europe getting sort of
pooped on but there's too much to sort
of do a deep dive all in one video all
in all a superb tournament that
delivered in a way that
i think we can all agree
siege needed speaking of delivering
things that siege needed
let's talk about the reveal panel touted
as the so-called year of siege ubisoft's
year 7 road map contained well just
about everything we as a community had
been clamoring for now i can't go over
every little deed
because there's a lot but i can
definitely cover the important bits
let's start with this coming season
which ooby has titled demon veil first
things first
the operator azami what does she do
well let's just say she's jet if jet's
knives could be thrown onto objects and
spawn bulletproof sage walls yes you
heard
jet knives sage walls
that is in fact what i said now to say
that this operator could be game
changing
is a gross understatement as some of
siege's craftiest creators have already
posited a zombie could very well be the
most sophisticated and complex operator
that has ever been introduced into siege
the possibilities her gadget presents
are the closest thing the game has ever
seen to endless and it is exciting as
hell demon vale is also bringing us a
goyo rework universal one-time sites a
new map called emerald plains attacker
re-pick and the team deathmatch mode
they demoed a while back we're also
getting the ranked phone verification
thing that ubisoft announced a few weeks
ago and i think i speak for all of us
when i say
thank
you
god as for what's coming throughout the
rest of year seven
buckle up [ __ ] from a ranked
rework to improved anti-toxicity
measures to r6 share changes to a
privacy mode reputation system and
improved onboarding system and yes
eventually a console fov slider the
message that ubisoft is conveying with
the year 7 roadmap is clear since well
the new creative director alex karpazis
literally said it my love for this game
and the team's dedication means that
we'll always be pushing for more on
siege we'll always try to push ourselves
to do better and to give more to you the
community and that's our promise to you
to be bigger and better in year seven
and in the future years to make sure
that siege is here to stay
and for the first time in a long time
i believe it
all right i'm here here i am drinking
the kool-aid you know why
because
ladies and gentlemen we are finally
getting a god forsaken practice range
[Applause]
i gotta be honest man i kind of never
thought this day would come no more
getting stewie2k pop flash by every t
every time you round a corner no sir
ubisoft have finally achieved the
miraculous feat of creating a static
unchanging room where i can walk in and
shoot at a wall in peace why did it take
so long
homie
i have lost
sleep wondering about that very same
thing
but who cares
the point is
we have it now oh and for those who were
clamoring during the panel where's the
end you cheat ubisoft kept good on their
promise and delivered it
just over a week prior so all of this is
excellent right like exactly what we
wanted
short answer
yes
long answer
hell yes
the year of siege is upon us and it is
not hopium in the slightest to say that
the future of our beautiful albeit
imperfect shooter
is looking very bright so how did
ubisoft not only fail to stick the
landing
but tail spin into chaos well you see
right at the close of the panel's
esports segment siege's director of
esports mentioned that the second major
of the year would be taking place in one
of two regions
europe or the middle east now the second
of those may have come as a bit of a
surprise until you remember that not
four weeks ago both esl and faceit with
whom ubisoft runs siege's esports
infrastructure were purchased by savvy
gaming who are backed by the saudi
arabian government's public investment
fund are they related are they not
related
who's to say the issue is that minutes
later
right as they were segueing into the
eulogy of siege caster and community
figure michael kickstar stockley who
passed away tragically last fall
a blog post was released detailing that
the major was slated in no uncertain
terms to be held in the united arab
emirates now i'm not saying that the
timing was purposeful on ubisoft's part
but even if it was an oversight
i don't need to tell anyone how
disrespectful that is for those who
aren't aware the uae is largely
considered to be one of the world's
worst human rights abusers on paper gay
relationships are illegal and punishable
under sharia law
trans identities are also illegal and
punishable
general ethical outrage aside there are
certain members of siege's talent desk
who publicly identify as lgbtq plus and
understandably we're afraid of
potentially risking their own personal
security should they attend the major
and just do their job suffice it to say
the community
was
livid literally everyone from casters to
creators to competitors to everyday
community members were taking to twitter
to make their objections heard what's
more the following day a petition was
uploaded to change.org
urging ubisoft to reconsider the
location of the august major
in what felt like one big swell of
support the community shared it on mass
taking a unified stand rainbow six siege
has always been a game about inclusion
and diversity both for the operators and
game and the community that plays them
it doesn't feel right to me to hold a
major event for this game in a country
whose government doesn't have those same
beliefs if you feel the same way click
on the link visit change.org and make
your voice heard and then after two days
of radio silence from ubisoft the
developer announced that they would in
fact be heeding the community's concerns
and finding a new yet to be determined
location for the major the community
rejoiced of course and immediately began
thanking ubisoft for how swiftly and
effectively they listened to feedback
that let's be honest should never have
been required to begin with still
they did listen and that's what matters
i'll be honest the tone of this video
was shaping up to be
very different until ubisoft made the
announcement that they would be
reverting their decision of course
there's no guaranteeing that siege and
esports in general will not again be
used to sportswash oppressive regimes
but for now at least we can rest assured
knowing that we were able to stave off
what is i hope not the inevitable future
of this esl facet acquisition i should
also reiterate as others in the
community already have that none of this
backlash was meant to be directed at the
people of the emirates nor their faith
or culture merely the government and the
laws they uphold there are those who are
using this as an excuse to be
islamophobic which is horrifying and
disgusting and not at all what this is
about the point was also not to stifle
the growth of middle eastern siege which
unfortunately has sort of been a
consequence of this cancellation as
conveyed by the heartfelt message shared
by middle eastern caster pisti this
region deserves attention and the hope
is that one day soon it'll get it
but maybe one day it will happen and
until then
all we want in my region
is to have our own land event we never
had one none of the huge name players
that are in my region ever had one
and those people deserve to be in the
sunlight for once in their life
and
anyway i was fine with that you guys
want to move it that's fine move it but
give it some attention
anyway in spite of all of that what a
killer invitation i'm really glad that i
get to end this video the way i always
anticipated which was by welcoming the
so-called year of siege and thanking
ubisoft's ridiculously hardworking
montreal team for giving us
everything we wanted and more i truly
believe that we are entering the second
age of siege and i hope that you are as
psyched as i am
to see how it unfolds
you understand that i could make a
[ __ ] mod a counter-strike mod
if i knew how to do that i don't know
how to do that but like if i knew how to
do it i could do it in like a week
one dude sitting in his computer i could
just make like a shooting range in
counter-strike and just upload it to the
steam workshop took ubisoft
six [ __ ] years
six [ __ ] years to give me a room that
i can just walk in and shoot at a
[ __ ] wall it gets me worked up